one of the most subtly hurtful and
quietly damning of
all remarks perhaps sweetly delivered on
the doorstep
at the end of a long evening with the
taxi still hovering somewhere just out
of sight
is the suggestion that we should in the
end probably
remain just good friends
we know exactly what to understand by
this
the path towards a tender future is
being gently but
firmly closed off we are with a smile
being shunted into the category of the
failed the ignored
and the lightly despised the other must
in some way have worked out the
despicable truths about us
all the ones that we tried so hard to
disguise and even to believe
didn't exist and has logically decided
to take their leave
we return crushed to an apartment which
we had left with butterflies and
elevated hopes only a few hours before
we hear the invitation to a friendship
as synonymous with insult
because our romantic culture has
continuously
from a young age made one thing sharply
clear to us
love is the purpose of existence
friendship
is the paltry depleted consolation
prize though this seems like
unsurprising common sense
what should detain us and encourage us
to probe a little at the claims
made on love's behalf is one basic
source
of evidence the behavior level of
satisfaction
and state of mind of those engaged
in love if we were to judge love
chiefly by its impact by the extent of
the tears
the depths of the frustrations the
viciousness of the
insults that unfold in its name we
wouldn't continue to rate it as we do
and might indeed mistake it for a form
of illness
or aberration of the mind the scenes
that typically unfold between lovers
would scarcely be considered imaginable
outside of conditions of open hostility
those we love we honor with our worst
moods
our most unfair accusations our most
wounding insults it's to our lovers that
we direct blame
for everything that's gone wrong in our
lives it's they we expect know
everything we mean without bothering to
explain it
it's to their minor errors and
misunderstandings
that we respond with sulks and rage
and by comparison in friendship the
supposedly
worthless and inferior state whose
mention should crush us at the end of a
date
we bring our highest and noblest virtues
here we are patient encouraging
tolerant funny and most of all
kind we expect a little less and
therefore by extension
forgive an infinite amount more we don't
presume that we will be
fully understood and so treat failings
lightly and humanely we don't imagine
that our friends should admire us
without reserve
and stick by us whatever we do and so we
put in effort
and behave pleasing ourselves as well as
our companions along the way
we are in the company of our friends our
best
selves paradoxically it's friendship
that offers us the real route to the
pleasures that romanticism
associates with love that this sounds
surprising
is only a reflection of how
underdeveloped our day-to-day vision of
friendship has become
we associate it with a casual
acquaintance we see once in a while to
exchange inconsequential
and shallow banter but real friendship
is something altogether more profound
and
worthy of exaltation it is an arena in
which two people
can get a sense of each other's
vulnerabilities appreciate each other's
follies without recrimination
reassure one another as to their value
and greet the sorrows and tragedies of
existence with wit
and warmth culturally and collectively
we have made a momentous mistake
which has left us both lonelier and more
disappointed than we
ever needed to be in a better world our
most serious goal
would not be to locate one special lover
with whom to replace
all other humans it would be to put our
intelligence and energy
into identifying and nurturing a circle
of true friends at the end of an evening
we would learn to say to certain
prospective companions
with an embarrassed smile as we invited
them inside
knowing that this would come across as a
properly painful rejection
i'm so sorry couldn't we just be
lovers
if you liked this film please subscribe
to our channel and click the bell icon
to turn on notifications